you
[Music]
the introduction welcome everybody i'll
me and create a me and char going to
walk you through the progress we have
made with CNT k how it is used and what
all are the key features that makes the
toolkit really attractive I am a ml
scientist with the Cintiq 18 and chose
the principal researcher and the dev
manager for CNT k we're going to talk
about the toolkit with respect to
scalability and speed of training as
well that is one of the key hallmarks
for what CNT k finds usage in a large
number of production loads that we learn
at Microsoft and increasingly with our
customers who are looking into
efficiency with which they can use these
resources in a cloud environment or in
their local setup to more efficiently
use their computer resource so I'm going
to primarily cover an overview and a
brief demo then charge is going to come
and talk about CNT k the key
differentiators and features and also
allude to some of the educational
resources that we have been putting
efforts behind so that you can possibly
leverage you and your colleagues if you
are trying to teach the next generation
how to do deep learning efficiently so
deep learning is as I was mentioning
power powering Microsoft in various
applications and end-to-end user
experiences so Microsoft cognitive
services Skype translator Cortana all
these technologies are empowered by C NT
k in one shape form or the other being
search being ads uses c NT k hololens
some of these things you have either
already heard in different kinds of
forums or you'll hear as I go along
speak and introduce briefly to the
different use cases and powering many of
the differentiators that make this
toolkit unique our researchers and their
contributions to the toolkit from acts
of research one of the hallmarks of C NT
k was scalability
this is demonstrated by the fact that
last year the speech researchers reached
a very historic moment in achieving
human parity with conversational speech
and what I want to emphasize is that if
when you are doing deep learning you
have to deal with large amount of data
the more data you throw at it for
practical problems it becomes more
amenable to achieving human-like
performance and you need scalability so
before using CNT K the iterative process
with which the research team was doing
the modeling was about six to eight
weeks and once the switch to CN ticket
they were able to iterate every week
every week and which led to reaching
them this landmark moment with agility
you can find more details in the paper
that is cited imagenet challenge is very
popular in computer vision and the
residual Network which is pretty much
where everybody starts today when they
do computer vision applications came
from Microsoft Research so we are very
proud about that moment and the I mean
if you look at the the new benchmarks
that are coming - from the image net it
is like incremental changes that are
happening over the 3.5 error rate that
was achieved in 2015 about two years
back today these technologies are
available to you in C and TK and even
more so in the form of recipes and
tutorials that even this beginner who's
new to deep learning can easily try
their hands on and figure out yeah you
know it's not that hard it's not black
magic it's pretty straightforward and
then go on to develop the next
generation innovation on top of it
cognitive services has a bunch of API
that people are using to build different
kinds of experiences in BOTS
in web services different kinds of
applications on their phones so vision
is one of the key areas where computer
but deep learning has made a huge impact
so face API emotion API as many of these
api's are available to
you and others who are using cognitive
services and they leverage CNT K as the
deep learning platform
similarly speech language knowledge
mining and search all of these use CNT K
in some shape form or the other I like
to get the interact with the audience so
how many of you have heard about or try
the how - all dotnet okay but yeah many
of you haven't please give it a shot and
if you have young kids at home give them
a chance to interact with it they get
familiar with AI they have fun along the
way my kids put a lot of different faces
on it and figure out how to break the
system and as you do so the machine gets
even better and better so these API is
these that are use behind the scenes
learn from the data that comes through
the different kinds of applications and
increasingly when and how the whole does
not started and now the accuracy of
predictions have gone significantly up
similarly caption but this generates
captions for images that you throw at it
is it can be occasionally quite funny
and it's interesting if you are just
curious throw some pictures at it and
you can get bemused by the captions that
come out some of them are scarily
spot-on so like this one I won't bother
reading it into it but it reads about
that there's a kid and he's kind of
neutral in his expression but also there
are other kids surrounding him and
interesting is that they have all their
faces that are facing backwards
leveraging these api's are startups the
sleep here is the company was working
with Microsoft in delivering a new
generation refrigerator where you are
able to identify things inside the
refrigerator using safety cap healthcare
is going through a revolution and E is
central to it so this company which
works with
ha ha tell you the 500 million people
with their business the vesicle has not
said FDR is one of the most common
complication of diabetes difference will
go bland results for achievement a dog
they are in various when there is need
to use just upload the photos and it
will give the diagnosis we leverage our
digital technologies are ended up with a
terror of the sorcerer like Linux -
Trinity's learning model the very event
with a lot of experience in the training
feature in poverty entities within
shorten the training time so we can
inherit our acrosome quickly and for
life in 24 servers which is reducible we
use a lot as your commercial
availability ensure our data security as
well as our mission critical service
level to our customers every day is a
great day because we're sending people
here's another customer who are using
some other toolkits and recently chose
to move over to using CNT K to leverage
the scalability and especially they
leverage the edge or stack the GPUs that
are available and they are delivering an
awesome experience in they've in doing
some image related tasks in this case
what was happening is they want to
scrape off different websites to find
what's the price of a given item should
be so previously they're using
text-based technologies which have it
doesn't go very well because the image
and clothing clothing go much better in
terms of a visual representation if it's
a flowery dress it is much easier to
compare with images than with text so by
switching over to deep learning models
using CNT K they are able to get very
very high accuracy and they when the
transition over from their previous
toolkit to CM ticket it was a rather a
very short duration in the matter of
less than a week they were able to
translate and scale across multiple GPUs
so when you get to using CNT K across
multiple GPUs it's pretty much a line of
code that allows you to just target all
the GPS that you want to go after the
setup is very very easy so in this case
the customer is seeking for in its
similarity and based on similar images
they scrape off prices and then build in
a price comparison database that they
then develop different user experience
on top of it Bing and Bing ads are big
CNT K users and they have bring a lot of
workloads to the toolkit and here you
leverage a lot of text and multimodal
datasets with images so in in this
left-hand panel you can see that here
the generate query with fruit is
highlighting the specific instances of
the fruits and this is not just a fruit
classifier this is generate language
understanding model that you can very
effectively build using deep learning
and deliver really
experiences on the right-hand side here
you're combining text with images where
you are able to decipher different
queries and match it with the assets the
visual assets that are being displayed
in this the search ad step is being
showed and you can search serve relevant
books in this case but also filter out
irrelevant ones and the malicious ones
are the ones that may not be quite
appropriate for the query you already
saw a demo on the translation
experiences that we are developing you
can go to this site and download and
download an app on your phone and then
given the number of languages we speak
in this room itself you can imagine that
if as I'm speaking in English and you
you are more comfortable with your
native language how much more richer
experience it would be if you could
deliver an accurate translation which is
not possible with the the Translate
effort that is leveraging deep learning
models behind the scenes this is also
made available to you through PowerPoint
so as you are as I'm presenting this
thing you could have a plug in
PowerPoint plug-in that is available to
you that would translate my talk into
subtitles or if you have the app going
along with it it will translate it into
your native language as well here is
another example of Skype translator
let's see let me quickly run it - it's
there often at times as we interact
across global boundaries we run into the
challenges where we are more comfortable
in speaking our native language but the
other person may or may not be
comfortable with or me that might be a
different language they want to choose
this youtube link actually has a nice
video for network reasons if I doesn't
load out will the slides have you'll
have access to the slides and you can
run it on your own machines and see with
Skype translator unless you have already
used the feature how convenient it is to
work across multiple language boundaries
it came up now
all right it's feature language these
two guests under seat proper but I
wanted to talk to you about the email
that I sent you yesterday coughs the
lavatory breaker and doorman do you need
any changes there was one thing though
could you change the green to a lighter
shade consider going to Shannon Hanuman
table tone n done yeah the comment of
twin feet Halima yes we can make the
green much brighter is it I'm going to
stop it here but you can watch the rest
of the video later on this is another
area of our deep learning really shines
which is the Microsoft customer support
agent how many of you have heard about
it okay
so three people in the room all right so
it is quite powerful and empowering
application of deep learning
it's powered by many many components but
C NT K is central to it the idea is that
you could leverage the corpus knowledge
corpus that is available to you using an
automated agent who can then deliver a
very nice experience now what this
experience would be let's walk you
through so somebody say comes to this
customer support agent and I'm sure you
have been on the phone with agents and
depending on human agents trained and as
you get into them you see a varying
degree of quality in this case the first
greeting that comes to comes to you is
from a bot that is our virtual assistant
and in this case the person actually
makes a very nice welcome and then you
can say that in your own natural
language that I'm having trouble setting
up a new projector for my laptop it's an
episode vs 240 now parsing this can be
challenging it may be natural to us but
the fact that this epsilon vs 240 is a
projector those associations are
automatically learned and very easily
done the deep learning so this agent
actually uses various components of deep
learning feed-forward Network LST ms and
we
and learning and a combination of these
to deliver the experience that I'm just
going to walk you through so in this
case the agent comes back and says that
this is the steps that you need to take
and then if you're not happy then the
agent tries to respond with an updated
answer a different one and the idea is
that you're interacting with the agent
all the time and at some point the
virtual assistant knows that it's not as
the answers they're delivering is not as
good as it should be or it's not
satisfying the end user and at that
point it can engage the right expert who
know the answer so this is leading to a
vast amount of savings and a huge
increase in customer experience this is
a wide open field for research and
innovations because the number of
questions you have in this world are
quite a few domains are different there
is a huge amount of opportunity I'm
going to skip this slide real quick
because Chris has already gone through
them and I will focus on some of the
things that really make CN TK attractive
to our community so this is some
benchmarking results by Hong Kong
Baptist University there's a group of
researchers who periodically compare
different toolkits and present their
results in this case the latest one that
they came up with presents en TK in a
rather very impressive way you can see
that that the number here the lower the
better it is the four different networks
it's a fully connected Network this
dialects net ResNet and LS teams how
much time does it take to the trainer
model on the different kinds of
different hardware that they have so you
can read the paper in in the link that
is out there but one thing that will pop
out to you is lsdm they saw the the
recurrence based networks that we have
because this came from the speech
Research Group the toolkit is uniquely
designed to be able to very efficiently
scale-up for these kind of networks very
efficiently to the compute but
as you go through the tutorials and the
material that we have for these networks
you'll find that it's really easy to
code for the students that I have taught
in the classes that's one of the
consistent feedback I get is that you
really make the recurrence much much
simpler I don't have time to explain to
you in much more details how it is done
but shall we'll get a little bit into it
but if you are really interested go
please take a time and go to the
tutorials and if there's a tutorial on
language understanding see in tk20 - you
can take a quick look at it and
hopefully it'll quickly transfer to how
easy it can be to build lick recurrences
and build classification and regression
models on top of it powering the
scalability is that not we didn't wake
up one fine day and just it works out
like right of the gate but it was been
the one of the key design tenets behind
the toolkit back in 2015 when no other
toolkits were supporting multiple GPU
servers c NT k was one of the first
toolkit that had it and subsequently now
the green bars pop up in every other
toolkit that is there it's kind of the
norm chris already has talked about us
delivering multi-gpu scaling so this is
a benchmark done using c NT k within our
partnership with nvidia here is another
example where n VDL d/dx computers have
CNT K enabled as one of the default
choices for computing and scaling across
the multiple GPUs that this machine
packs Chris has already walked you
through this particular the plot below
but I would like to additionally
emphasizes our not only the scalability
but giving state-of-the-art recipes
available to you and working conditions
across multiple platforms is also a very
key important aspect of CNT k in this
case we have rendered and vidya CEO with
because of style using a neural style
rendering and this is available to you
as a tutorial have your own painting I
have your own picture painted in your
preferred style CN tk20 files the
tutorial
you want to know how it works few lines
of code it's not shouldn't take you too
long to understand how what how to make
it work there is another example for
scalability f knits
crayons them their partnership with us
in scaling up deep learning platforms on
their supercomputer with 1000 nvidia
tesla p hundred GPUs alright just a
quick summary some of the key advantages
for CNT k are the B hub besides the
scalability part that I talked about is
our support now we have for Python and
the C++ API is mostly implement it's
mostly implemented in C++ with both low
level and high level Python api's are
available to you we provide
extensibility so if you have your own
functions users can extend those api's
with user functions and learner's in
pure Python readers we didn't get a
chance to talk much about readers today
readers are key to deep learning so if
you are going to build a model that fits
all in memory or you have all the data
sitting in our given hard disk it's
relatively easy to kind of randomly
chunk them and feed it into the modeling
pipeline but when you get to very
large-scale applications like the ones
we deal with at Microsoft it is no
longer that easy to do that
randomization and balance the compute
load with the i/o load so the Cintiq 8
videos that are distributed to you comes
out of the box capable of scaling to a
large large amount of data so when you
build your prototypes by using these
leaders automatically it will scale up
when you build a real application so
that's one of the reasons many of these
customers who are coming to us are
constantly surprised at how little time
it takes for them to build scalable
architecture so from an academic
standpoint it also becomes very
important to keep that in mind as we are
paying attention to modeling and solving
those models that the entire pipeline
has to be kept in mind when building
these recipes or coming up with new
solutions
that bring differentiation and
breakthroughs and deep learning
community a couple of things I would
like to highlight the scaris
interoperability with Cintiq a backend
it's the one line change if you have
Kara setup on your machine with tons of
flow or Tiano
you could just switch this back in to
see ntk and leverage some of the
benefits that the toolkit provides you
can interchangeably train models and run
them or @cn TK and I'm going to demo a
reinforcement learning example with dqn
where the model was training intensive
flow and we are running it in CNT care
you can do vice-versa it literally took
me 20 minutes to get this thing going
it was not too hard to get this Kara's
example a recipe that's out there to run
on CNT came and you get the benefits of
whatever I have talked so far about CNT
K by doing so and Chris did allude to
about model compression and binary
evaluation is very very key to it yeah
this is another example I will shortly
show to you so for the reals more
reinforcement learning this is a flappy
bird example where you follow the
following steps you have the grain
scheme in input you pre process the
image then you have a convolution net
and then you predict with that the bird
should clap or not and you use key
learning to maximize the reward you can
find the original code at this github
site in the screen here and this is the
model that got trained and let me see if
I can quickly do a demo of this
so
all right
so this train takes a long time for
reinforcement learning things but
because we are using a tensor flow model
and running it it's pretty
straightforward I also have the training
code in the example Italy shortly
release in the one of the as one of the
examples in Cintiq a github site all
right I have one last demo after that
I'll give it to Shah
so here is the the binary evaluation
videos all right so with without binary
evaluation and with binary evaluation
you can see that things work a lot
faster and on the CPU it works very very
efficiently you can get seven to ten
times speed up without loss of much
accuracy shall we do I will take
questions at the end I think right
okay hear me yeah okay good so saying
give you an introduction of what you
know all the application scenarios and
you know general advantages of CNT k so
my part of the talk I'm going to dive a
little deeper and tell you a bit about
you know why we can how we can make
Cindy K so far so basically I'm going to
talk about three things
the symbolic loop in Cindy K how we do
batching for recurrent networks that
make a Cintiq is recurrent so fast also
talked a little bit about data parallel
training so Cynthia express the
arbitrary networks and by composing
simple building blocks into a complex
graph and then it basically supports all
kind of networks so to use that example
let me start with this a very simple two
hidden layer neural networks it's a
feed-forward network it contains two
linear layers with the sigmoid and then
at the end you have a soft Max and
that's the network so it's a very very
simple and for those of you who have
been playing with deep networks before
you know that you also need to define a
loss function so here we use a very
standard crowd entropy you know trained
criteria I just Y transpose log of the
probability generated by self max so
converting this basic math equations
into Python this is how we represent
this model in in Cincy k so you
basically write h1 is the sigmoid of X
is a vector times a matrix w1 plus a
bias so you literally just write these
equations in Python and you end up with
this script so once you write that
script since UK will then compile it
into a graph so a graph looks like the
one on the left-hand side so you notice
that the bias the weight matrix is this
and the input X all becomes inputted to
some notes where these nodes are little
we just functions they do multiplication
they took Plus they do softmax and then
at the end you have a softmax layer and
the cross-entropy layer and so the
reason we do this conversion into a
graph is obviously I mean it makes it
just for one big reason that is to do
automatically differentiation and so
once you have the graph structure it's
very easy to derive for any of the nodes
in the graph what is the derivative of
it with respect to the loss with respect
to any of the notes inside a graph and
so this differentiation is completely
automatic and then we have differed
computation which will execute this
graph at high speed so this is a design
I think a pioneer by piano and then you
know took by both tensor flow and Cintiq
as well so it's a static graph compile
and then run very fast the graph is
editable you can clone this as well so
it's like a Lego you can compose and
trying to build all kind of networks so
the three unique things I'm going to
talk about symbolic loops parallel
training with mini batching and cross
GPU parallel training so let's take this
example that we just had and extend it a
little bit let's make it a recurrent
Network so to make a return Network what
we need to do is basically in the linear
equation that we had before we're going
to add a one more term so in the first
equation of each one we're adding a time
variable and then the H one T is going
to be depend on H 1 t minus 1 which is
the previous time step and you take the
H 1 t minus 1 you multiply a matrix R 1
and so this is basically so on the left
hand side are these equations so you can
easily understand that and on the Python
side Cintiq a has a keyword called path
value so essentially just write password
you of h1 and then times a matrix R 1
and this is all you do in Python so you
can see how easy it is to write a
recurrent Network in CNT k very
straightforward so inside the Cintiq a
once we saw this the the Centegra so
this code had basically represent this
thing this recurrence ain't ask value as
a symbolic loop so this is the red
circles inside the graph so basically I
mean this is speech so we're familiar
with all these z-transform signal
processing kind of stuff so Z minus 1 is
the time delay and then you have this
graph that represent how the whole
network should look like and once once
the graph is built then syndicate
automatically unrolls
the circles at execution time and so
circles are detected with Hodgins
algorithm and then the only include node
in the cycles and then it can be run
very efficient and composed very easy to
compose with others now just as a
comparison if you write the same
recurrent network in terms of flow this
is before the one point 1.0 release
where they simplify writing recurrent
networks this is how you're going to
write in a low-level API so it's much
more complicated you have to manually
unroll things which is not easy to
understand
the second major feature of sin TK which
is also looted from the kind of gene of
the speech gene of sin TK is to handle
variable length sequences so in either
speech or in language processing where
you have sentences of different lenses
for example you know there are training
samples that are maybe 20 water long
there are sentences which are 5 world
around so how do you put them together
and train and so most of the other
toolkit which I think probably every
other toolkit out there
does this bucketing thing where they
trying to put similar lengths
consists into one pocket one made a
batch and then try and train it the the
issue with that approach is certainly
you kind of disrupted the randomization
of the training data so manually you're
doing some organization of the data
where for one minute that you only see
long sequence one minute base you only
see short sequence so what we want to do
in Cindy case somewhat differently so we
want to basically have these long and
short six sequences being able to train
in a single mini batch now if you just
detect them row by row and train them as
a mini batch then you realize that you
got a lot of so the sequence one is
running or sequence two already finished
because the GPU gets hungry and does
nothing and so that makes most of the
recurrent implementation of others for
kids are very slow because the GPU is
idle is not doing any job
so in CNC K we have this idea called the
batching which essentially concatenate
the shorter sequences into a longer one
so in this particular case if the
toolkit realize that the total length of
sequence two and three sum up is less
than the sequence one they will just
schedule them into the same slot so that
particular chip processing unit handling
this particular sample can run a lot
longer than before
now this looks trivial but in reality
maybe thirty forty percent of the
intricate code is handling how do you
you know treat this boundary when you
switch from sequence two to sequence
three where the state need to be
reinitialized
and during a value to handle things so
this is complicated but we done this or
inside Cintiq a user is completely
unaware of any of these packing
happening you just write your code
randomize your data and just send it
into the in TK you don't need to worry
about anything for this so it's fully
transparent so recur so we basically
have three levels right so recurrent
since you can unroll you don't need to
unroll manually
for the parallel training you don't need
to worry about matching them and during
the eval you don't need to worry about
how to mask them to do sequence
reductions and the last kind of feature
I like to mention is the parallel
training of syndicate
there are basically different levels of
parallel training if it's one single
vector sample usually that's called
vector right prioritization and then
across multiple samples with the record
batching and then we have across
multiple GPUs
this is async PCIe device-to-device
transfer as well as across multiple
servers this requires MPI and that's
what we use and also lately I think
during the latest Nvidia GPC just in May
they demonstrated using sync UK working
with Nico 2.0 that's a cross machine
transmission communication protocol that
can be used to speed up cross machine
training so for C NGK we focus mostly on
data power training because we believe
that's kind of the most natural way of
handling paralyzation
we haven't seen you know many models
that is so big their current GPU cannot
hold well we see a lot of advantage of
doing data parallel training so this is
kind of the very naive way of doing data
parallel training so essentially you
have use you have a bun mini bunch mini
batch of data you send into a multiple
nodes then these notes does do their you
know gradient descent calculate the
gradient automate themselves and then
you run it all reduce by taking all
their gradient some in two together and
then redistribute back into all the
nodes now this certainly creates a
bottleneck at the no to who does the
summation of all the gradients and it
can set
be improved so a better algorithm would
actually be basically slice the model
into multiple chunks and then ask each
of the node to handle one specific chunk
and so you can see that here basically
the first chunk is handled by another
one for example and then two and three
now both send their particular gradient
for that chunk to node one for
aggregation so every node does part of
the model and then at the end you
basically exchange these partial
gradient aggregate with a gradient of
the model back to all the nodes until
you do synchronization so this is well
known algorithm called a ring it's
essentially a one respected to K where K
is the total number of nodes so it's
it's considered a quite efficient way of
doing synchronous gradient descent now
remember that you know the the Cintiq I
started with the speech model so at that
time most of the models are speech
models and speech at that time mostly
used as connected layers so if you take
a typical dense connected layers with
the many batch size say
1024 say the typical model having 160
million model parameters and you can see
that the amount of time to compute these
gradients is about one seventh of a
second while the communication is about
one ninth of a second so you cannot even
paralyze this task into two GPUs because
the communication cost already dominates
the whole thing so what's in ZK of
course there has been a lot of paper at
that time doing asynchronous training
and however it does not really change
the problem fundamentally because all
the gradients did have to be transmitted
so we have basically at the same GK we
have looked into two possible ways to
reduce communication cost the first way
which is quite
well known in the toolkit the planning
toolkit literature it's called a one-bit
SD d so instead of transmitting the
whole precision gradient across these
machines the idea is that
let's quantize this gradient into one
bit so you got one bit quantized when
you send from node 2 node 3 to node 1
for aggregation and then also one bit
quantized when you send across to all
the nodes back for aggregate for
composing the overall gradient and model
and the of course when you do such heavy
quantization you lose accuracy and the
trick that we have this is a paper by
Frank cite a number of MSR researchers
is to carry over the quantization error
into the next mini batch and it turned
out this works very well essentially the
communication costs reduced by a factor
of a 32 and it enables us to Train
really large speech models in production
clusters with a very fast and high
scalability the next idea is basically
to communicate less often so the this
actually contains two works the first
idea is called automatic mini batch
siding essentially what this research
has done is that at the very beginning
of a deep learning model training you
tend to use smaller many registers
because it's crucial to have a smaller
mini batch size to make sure the model
converges to high accuracy however when
it goes towards the you know when you
have like the 5 10 15 a box in they find
that now you can safely increase the
size of the mini batch you can make the
mini batch size to even add order I
think believe on the order of 100,000
speech models and so this drastically
improve the training speed of cdk
large production scale work workload so
this paper was published in ICAST 2014
similar idea has been recently presented
by Facebook Retina 50 where they were
able to Train 250 on 256 GPUs for
residency in one hour so we have this in
over four three years already and then
the second idea is called the block
momentum I'm not going into details
about how this algorithm works but
essentially it's a combined model
average with some error residual idea by
looking at each of the nodes update as
gradient update where we add on top
momentum term to make the gradient
update more smooth and that turned out
to work extremely well even better than
the one bit STD so all these have been
included in the SDK and you can just
play with it so I talked a lot of this
mostly I kind of focused on the speech
aspect of you know how these are
designed but I want to also mention that
today's indica is much more broader than
working on the speech tasks so as Sonia
had a shoulder earlier a lot of people
have been using the mck for image tasks
language tasks and they were all very
successful so I think this is the last
section I'm going to briefly talk about
if you want to give CNT a try what are
the resources you have so we think the
best place to start you know learning
about Cindy case goes through these
tutorials so since EJ has a long list of
tutorials I think it's probably today's
over 15 of them essentially explain how
you can use the implicit to do simple
tasks like you know creating a
feed-forward Network I'll do two
covenants with m-net
the red net how do you predict the stock
market how do you do
forecasting using data from IOT device
etc so there's a lot of star transfer
text translation etc so just read them I
think it's a good education for both
what is deep learning as well as how you
can use 50 K to solve these tasks and
Cindy K as mentioned earlier is the
completely open source with MIT license
on github so you can go to github
syndicate github maintain a main page
and there are three major sources the
tutorials I just mentioned we also have
a lot of examples I want to say a bit
about these examples so if you go to
other toolkits in particular I mean we
recently experienced like MX net where
they have you know examples but some of
the example you cannot even run there's
even typos in the script you essentially
cannot run this example the in cindy
kaye we actually spend a lot of time
verifying them by verifying we mean that
researchers actually taught models from
other toolkits and we spend a lot of
time making sure that these models are
running as they they should be so I
think most of you probably heard about
Google's inception v3 model which is you
know Google made it and then release
open source the model but nobody was
able to train the inception v3 model
even on tensorflow you cannot get the
identical accuracy so researchers in our
team basically spend a lot of effort and
we were able to create the inception v3
model essentially with accuracy that
matches the even surpasses the original
paper so that took us like a month to do
such kind of job but we believe it's
very valuable that we make sure our
models examples are really high quality
and you can reproduce numbers we also
recently with a lot of requests adding a
new section called manuals
explains better if you want to say debug
cindy kaye what you want to do things
like that if you don't have if you don't
want to even download the scene okay
here's another resource you can go to
this agile notebooks these are free
notebooks just go to Microsoft edge your
notebooks and go there and they're a
bunch of total there you can just read
them I think they are also good resource
for you to say teach students because
you know it's freely accessible by
everyone C&T case documentation has been
also improved quite a bit we have a
dedicated website for all the
documentation the Python is a different
documentation set which is also very
easily searchable and Ssangyong and
Roland another scientist in Microsoft
also created the EDX course on deep
learning and CNT K so you guys can give
it a try
so as a conclusion since ek is fast
scalable extensible some of the unique
features make Cintiq a really send out
particularly if you handle any of the
recurrent networks it's extremely fast
we're saying about 5 to 10 X faster than
any other toolkit out there and you can
verify yourself and we have a lot of
educational resource and you can take a
look at them and it is a completely open
source project we also welcome your
contributions you know we're trying to
cultivate a community it takes some
efforts but you know we think it will be
good to have a large community working
on the toolkit and that's all we have
thank
[Applause]
we can take some questions
ugly
yeah yeah I can take question afterwards
hello can you hear me hello okay hello
everyone I'm yami-chan from Shanghai
Georgia birthday in China today I'm very
glad to join this session and have the
opportunity to talk about the research
in my laboratory and we have seen
special recognitions that have been
deployed in many applications however
there are still many unsolved problems
when making the machine to transcribe to
transcribe at the real with the real
world of speech everywhere
today I will mainly talk about the new
challenges in speech recognition and the
present of the corresponding
technologies and the recent progress
developed in Sgt youth speech lab
another main feature about the
technologies which I will talk about
today that all the advances and
achievement were developed with
assistance from the CNT case there has
been a long research on speech
everything has been long history and the
task needed to recognize the water
sequence when giving the speech waveform
as the observation the problem can be
formulated as this objective to
recognize to find the best award
sequence trouble you to maximize the
proprietary pw0 is the observation by
the fear by the patient's the area and
the chain rules this objective can be
furthered composing into 4 probabilities
which are related to the four modules
insufficient assistance they are
featuring searching across model like
model and the language model the
decoding process we are integrating all
the knowledge from the four modules to
obtain the final speech definition
result thanks to the circles of innocent
achievement on deep learning
technologies during the current years
there has been a great progress on
speech recognition more and the more
speech definition applications has been
supposed to the threshold for adoption
in some real-world scenarios and the
enable the services such as the
Microsoft katana upon Siri Google now to
be commonly used
and more recently the speaker product
received more received tremendous
increases from the industry such as
Amazon echo Google home
Microsoft invoke and the iPhone part six
is also showed in saga and the child's
life this is the progress on the famous
famous task on telephone speech
recognition on sujod here leads to the
system comparison during the last few
last few years the first bar is the best
assistance to using the shadow model in
2011 and the others are the method that
uses a different inverted approaches
later last year and the early this year
well both Microsoft and IBM obtained the
new word Erik mouth so below 6.0% which
are also known stood to achieve human
parity however I wanted to ask if it
really good enough to make the machine
to transcribe the real world speech
everywhere and that the speech defeating
technology is really achieved human
territory actually there are still many
unsolved problems and I summarized a
list here which are also the new the new
challenges and the result frontier in
speech recognition they are annoyed
robust multi-genre low resource mix on
multilingual low computation and the
rich transcription today I will discuss
some of them and present the related
technologies and the progress in our lab
the first one I want to mention is not
robot speech recognition has been
claimed that to achieve the high
accuracy however most of them are still
construing the using is a clean
collegial speech with close talk
microphone I think everyone have seen in
the in the keynote afternoon and the
Microsoft have said have the speech
transcription systems for the speakers
but I can see that every speaker needed
needed a girl talk Maxim
and in the relative quiet environment so
the signal signal noise ratio is higher
although we have used the different
loading based method there are few large
applications when deployed the speech
recognition system in the northeast
scenario such as the bus station coffee
house meeting room when creating all
kinds of original types of vibrations
and the channel Distortion
the main problem for noisy noise robots
official definition is the mismatch
between training and testing the system
in fragile in the reality due to the
mismatch from the background noise
channel speaker accent and and other
factors in the reality although we can
collect a much data but the scenarios
the in reality are so many that we can
cover we can not cover all the
conditions at the patient is one
effective method to reduce the mismatch
so how to use it
utilize the limit in the data to do
faster and the effective adaptation in
one main research topic for noise robots
of speech recognition similar adaptive
search strategies are developed in our
lab the first wise name the cluster
adaptive training in this method the
multiple bases are formed to
constructors of canonical parametric or
space for example we can use layer way
to merge quickly as the basis in the end
on future Maxon filters as basis in
theorem drug eradication we only need
two estimators in installation vectors
to combine the different different bases
to form the final adaptive model since
we only need to predict and update the
installation vector so the number of
parameters are very smaller than the 15
year based adaption method here are some
experimental results under the different
scenarios wine for DM is the cluster
adaptive training another
the fear-based clustered up between you
can see our proposed method can get a
very large significant improvement on
the different scenarios and the
proprietary selection is very important
when input when it when implemented the
cluttered up training for speech
recognition
another method is named the
environmental where training we want the
different models can predict and
perceive the environment change always
so that the models can adjust the
parameters simultaneously to address the
environmental variability in this method
the factual representation is the food
stamp different from the conventional
approaches deals are used to do all
federal representation including speaker
for rule north type and so on and then
we design the information exchange
mechanisms to integrate all the factors
into the main speech revolution models
and these mechanisms also enable all the
modules can benefit from each other
another advantage is that this is people
model-based effectors are not ruled out
as the traditional factors and all the
factors can be combined to get another
additional implement in addition to the
adaptation we also explore the aquifer
model in the neutral aqua modeling which
can to the automaticall nor remove
removing embodied so that in the
explicit adaptation annoyed removing are
not needed inspired by the vdg and the
rest nature in image processing we also
explore the similar structure with
suitable adjustment in speech
recognition and first time here leads to
some very difficult network
architectures in our experiment we find
we find that the proprietary in padding
and input channel usage are very
important to use speech recognition
here's the result comparison on the
different models we can see to propose a
very deeper convenient new network
achieved promising results in the noisy
scenarios and it is much better than the
recurrent internet worker uses nor the
scenario with the in-depth analysis we
can find a very difficult convolution
your network can reduce the noise
embedding and that you can you can in
order on deliberation gradually across
the step collusion layers more detail
can be referred to our transmission
paper to take all to tickle on the
advantages method mentioned above we
further integrated all the technicals
into one framework to get more advanced
assistance some architectures are lived
here and that we found in the system
performance can be further significantly
positive with all these technologies now
let's have a look at the system
comparison on the standard the standard
and all these speech definition Pascal
or Roth for here Lister the best and
system performances for each year over
the last last five years and the first
bar is the previous system using the
shallow models which are developed in
the Canberra University in 2012 the last
ones the last ones are three terms of
using the typical model and the Liberata
with the dashed line box are developed
in our lab we can see during the twenty
the last three years our systems which
are developed using the mentioned above
mentioned the technologies go to the
best systems and particularly the listen
to obtain the result of 5.7% water it is
a new milestone on a raffle it is a
field progress for noise robot speech
recognition
okay the second challenge I want to
mention is multi general most of
currents and spiritual applications are
mainly focused one focus on one genre or
one condition such as the speech input
or voice or our mobile and the telephone
on reading transcription system if you
do one application is the to the other
conditions that the general on the topic
of mismatch is very large so the equity
will decrease in somatically so how to
construct a general speech recognition
system to process this kind of multi
journal data is very challenging the
data are from BBC on YouTube is kind of
data another difficulty is from the
complex audio and the low quality
transcript because the different audios
are recorded with the different
scenarios and it has a different
background noise and the speech type is
also unknown animal and the most of
these most of these from the program is
have the subhead hold so the water area
is very high on the transcript it's
nearly approached 38 to 40 percent water
areas for the labels and even no
accurate time for these levels so how to
build a system using this kind of data
will be very difficult now let's watch a
video to better understand what is
called a multi channel foot
all the time always British really
pretty tight pants I like I'm European I
like it you know I just whatever try to
get her into tighter pants he's like
nope that's gay no pulse mitt like right
that British between the circle down to
our left perfect picked up by Steph
Curry six to shoot
he's in the right boy these cutters FD
oximetry
[Applause]
be dramatic and you go
George a all-new are coming
see one so can see the general
difference in very large between the
different programming so build of the
transcription system for the plate
height very challenging to better
utilize this kind of data
the first step is how to do the subtitle
alignment so we can get more equity
transcriptions and the time information
is for system beauty so diverse audio
and the diverse transcriptions as a two
main difficulty and the library
supervisor alignment free work is
designed including the stages such as
like the supervised decoding stability
point detection settlement emerging
non-speech suit and the data collection
this is a demo for the alignment here
there are three lines the first a green
line is the original subtitles provided
by BBC and the second a yellow line is
the realigned output out from our final
thicker and the we don't need to care
the last lines that are just the white
line just as a temporary output around
our system we just needed to compare the
first green line to the second yellow
line
[Music]
got a weapon
exactly then Darla things they've only
got one I could squad your paint that
they've blind it we're not going to
enemy Nora your buckets on the house
Simon Dean time
you can see the time the time
information about the subtitles can be
improved significantly after the data
reflecting on the subtitles and then we
can do the oaks model and a lambda model
for the octave modeling we uses a deeper
model based the hybrid and the tendency
terms and then the different Fe term can
be combined there using the gender
decoded
moreover the critical depth is also
implemented on this kind of Akutan model
to reduce the architects condition
mismatch which can improve the genre
with my mismatch significantly for the
language model the Ricardian Turner
network based the language model with
topical adaptation were developed it has
been implemented to do the faster
lattice recording to obtain better
speech recognition systems a speech
recognition result here the demo for the
transcription system and they are also
three lines the first green line is the
menu transcription the menu transcript
machine and the second a yellow line is
the output the from the official
released baseline return and the surfer
the white line is the output from our
beta system we can do them some
comparison with the different lines
perfect for us congratulations all of
the Clarence station and that was a nice
way to celebrate today yeah was in
describing multi
about about individuals you know today
was a real team performance
adjust the athletes and I that all
season and obviously cannot only get
food on we get ahead of ourselves now
it's a great one for us but now we need
to get ready supply of nick's like we
thought probably about this game being a
bit of a try fest but we we talk about
how to certain down other within the
tremendous job unfortunately after
[Applause]
giving the time we hadn't been conquered
by factor while bath were they taking
second spot wats we're taking their
place I've been behind early on at
renovated lead they ran in a hat full of
tribes the main beneficiary being Tom
Ford's back from injury and grabbing a
hatchet and wrap out even eight winning
the worst side of the reason would say
because yes output of our system is much
better than the bit slack and the equity
the even approaches the manual
transcription systems and the disease
can also get the MGB challenging in 215
because the first collision the last
challenge I wanted to mention the
cocktail party problem in speech per
second this is the definition for hotel
party problem from chairing in the
middle of last century one of our most
important of secretaries is our ability
to listen to and follow one speaker in
the presence of others this is such a
common experience that we may take it
for granted we may call it a cocktail
party problem it is easy for humans but
it is very difficult for the machine to
do perfecting with this kind of data
humans who can process as many as six
interference talker with the equally
loud speech but in contract the true
total mix of speech is even very hard
for the machine for the machine
processing in the cultural parking
environment we are mainly focused on
three problems the multi local speech
separation which aims to separate and
the trees the stream of the mixes the
speech the multi local speechless
not only to do the speech separation we
only need to recognize what has been
said in each string multifocal speaker
identification in addition to the
content of the mixer stream we also
wanted to know who are speaking in this
mix of three the first one is multi
caucus speech separation the traditional
method that are normally unsupervised
including the casa lms secretory IgA
mm-hm based on with the increase we
always increase the interest on
differently people learning the deeper
models started to convert the problem
from unsupervised learning problem to a
supervised the one however previous deep
learning based methods that can only
work well user seen speakers on the
specific interferences it cannot work
very well on the unseen speakers mainly
due to the label permutation problems
the label permutation problem problem is
that when giving the mix of speech we
don't know whether it is a plus B on B
plus a so we cannot assign some
supervision for the individual output of
corruptly fifty pictures shows that the
traditional differently based most
method for the sweet separation we can
see we we assign the fixed order
supervision for the two output but due
to the label permutation problem this
assumption is not very accurate to
address these problems we propose that
the permutation very invariant training
method
the motivation is easy one giving the
mix of the mix of speech for speed
separation we actually don't care it is
a plus B or B plus a we only care the
quality of the separated single speech
so in P IT training which which is a
which which will dissolve partner as a
set and during the treating the first
determines it photos it first determines
the best
out
the target assignment to minimize the
error at the attenti level based on the
fourth for the past and adult and then
optimize a model using this assignment
the PRT training can automatically
determines the label Tibetan label
assignment to base the current model and
it can be used to separate the multiple
speech stream it can also be easily
extended a tool even more because
through speaker on fourth speaker and
another advantage is that it only
affects the training and the no actual
processing a during the separation this
picture shows the attention for the P I
teach meaning you can see the main
differences on the top it will do the
parallel scoring on the output to
determine the best label labeled happy
the assignment said the similar idea I
extended to the multicultural speech
recognition previous method can only do
the multi local speech recognition on
the scene speakers and with relatively
easy tasks such as the eyes isolating
the world of speech recognition and the
is normally you needed explicit speech
separation plus and normal speech
recognition modules to do the whole
pipeline we extended the PRT training to
speech recognition and evaluators the
criterion on the cross engine cross
entropy level it can do the separation
treating internal engine in one short
without her and explains the separation
stage after the model training which
between the PRT models can recognize the
multiple the multiple speech streams
increases in the mixers mixture audio
simultaneously here the after chose for
the PRT training is the most local
speech recognition this is this is the
experimental result on the edge we need
for multifocal special finishes the top
small one is the normal single speaker
model to recognize the normal single
speaker
single
single typical speech it is meeting
transcription 50 copper's named Donnie
and this bottle one is that we use Rison
a single speaker model to recognize the
mixed the to total mix of speech
directory from the results we can see
the ability of the single Civic model is
limited to recognize the multi locals
Nixon speech and there are very large
depredations for both two speakers and
especially for the low energy speaker
the water area is even higher than 100%
it is demonstrated the high challenging
for this park and this last table is a
result using our proposal TI teach
meanings of multifocal speech
recognition we can see there are both
very large improvement on both two
speakers for different SLR although so
what allottee are still very high and
far and far from the real implementation
but it is still very promising
the last one is multifocal speaker
identification we want to know who are
speaking in this cocktail party
environment the traditional method also
will use the explicit switch separation
and the speaker identification stages
and the normal shadow models will be
used for this task
recently a and to end the deep learning
based approaches proposed for this task
in this model the speech waveform on
speech features are fading into the
specific models and the K or diverges
evaluated between the output of the
deeper model and the sort of speaker
labels which are obtained from the
energy ratio mark after the model
training in the 13 we just needed to
calculators the items level score to do
the final decision to obtain who are
speaking in this mixed term speech these
accessories are also very easy to
extended for more speakers three on five
four and five speakers
now let me show you some samples we
evaluating this method on two kinds of
coppers why is the normal English
English multi-protocol speech and
another is a more difficult Chinese song
colors first let let us lessons and
samples this is the normal to mixed
speech to a to know connected speech
keep 116 games this is the fourth local
mr. speech brain okay for the colors it
has Chinese song see the tree in the
fourth speaker the tadka on the chorus
is much difficult because all the time
the frequency champions are almost the
same between the different speakers so
it is infeasible to do the normal speech
separation first with the traditional
method the table shows the result with
end to end a different matter to do this
speak ID or multilocular mix the speech
and we can see this method can get very
high accuracy on the normal multifocal
mix of speech the result on the chorus
is relatively much worse but it is still
very promising if using the traditional
method as a shallow model the error rate
is nearly approaching 19th and 1980 at
the last I wanted to talk about the to
cater in our development society K was
using in our lab since 2014 and the full
name is still come computational neural
network to key to death and it is
initially developed in the speech and
the dialogue group in back consult for
speech recognition C's to speech speech
within the applications but now it is
not only for speakers of speech but also
for other air tasks we also tried the
other two meeting in our lab but we
found that the CNT can make the model
training and the city building more
flexible efficient and effective and all
the advances mentioning in my talk are
developed with the assistance from the
CNT case here are the main reference
about the technologies I mentioned it is
talk finally I wanted to thank for my
colleague and the student est tu thanks
for the collaboration with Microsoft and
the sentence for the vintage jeans
thank you very much
[Applause]
yes so thanks for this impressive
presentation my my question is how long
can this precision can be maintained for
instance this is for the for the ten
seconds let's say segments we have or it
can be extended two minutes or longer
dialogues between speakers how how long
yes what is the length of the pitch so
intervening on Kathy
whatever actually it is very difficult
to collect the data for this week for
this multi-tow convicted speech so we
needed to see me to do some simulations
to do the documentation to obtain very
large for very large data set
unfortunate and the impacting the length
is only about three seconds and to five
seconds it is not very long
hi I have a question for the CN TK team
so we have seen lots and lots of
frameworks over the years and every
company seems to want to build their own
new framework and first of all what is
your thought on it if you think this is
healthy and the second thing is if you
don't think it's healthy what is the way
out of it
all right that's a that's a very good
question oh yes
every company want to build their own
toolkit from Microsoft released from our
perspective I think at a certain point
there will be some standardization of
the toolkit there has been already like
high level tool kits like Karis become
really popular and they have right now
that kinds of see a notice of loss in TK
and I think a MEK net is also building a
bad kind of work errors so I think
overall I see basically you can build
the industry standard for to two levels
one is that to the API level high level
API where everybody can like think like
Karis another level is at the graph
level where the intermediate
representation that's used to compile
code into execution that's a level I
think currently there are also a lot of
efforts in building the intermediate
penetration and we see some opportunity
there and we'll see how it depends on
yeah the other thing is the problem
domains that each of these different
toolkits face are quite unique in their
own business sense so in aggregating
those they attack the problems in a very
different way for instance you see the
CNT case strength comes in the
recurrence domain right mean it was very
obvious to you so having a cohort of two
kids really enables you to build risk
best of the breed and at some point when
you come together we just make the whole
ecosystem of deep learning so much
richer and then the good part is all of
these are in open source
thanks to the talks now I also have a
question to the entik a team so I was
wondering when you distill the model at
the end like into the binary format to
run it faster like what kind of
resources that does that require can
that run on a phone yes so if you look
at the one bit convolution that seong
demonstrated so in that particular case
we're using halide which is a compiler
deck and compiled code into all kind of
devices
I think tensorflow is doing Excel a
which is kind of very similar so so yeah
I see that as currently you know the if
you want to create models that cannot
execute really fast on different devices
that seems to be a very good way to
achieve that I would say that's true for
the evaluation part so you'll see you
know with the things like the one bit
compression you'll see evaluation move
to you know low computational devices
like the phone but training still
remains the province of cloud yeah so
what I've found in my deep learning
research is that we often look at using
various two kids but then we wind up
rolling around code because the toolkits
are too narrow in what they do which
maybe is fine for doing standard
applications with in the standard
architectures and doing backdrop but
whatever you know do you have any
thoughts about making for example C and
D K more flexible yeah which would be
more useful services but then also in
the long term you know might help might
actually help it yeah you know
prevailing in industrial applications so
extensibility is the one of the things
that I mean I think I mentioned we
mentioned a slide but didn't really
expand much so in some of extensibility
for CNC K almost every component is can
be written in a custom way so since you
case supports extended custom learners
customer custom readers for some layers
whatever you want to write we basically
expose the interface
what people can write C++ or Python code
to be integrated with cindy kaye
actually recently we've been working on
some models that we literally just took
some cafe layers in Python and we just
you know from cindy kaye calling to
python and do the calculation and come
back to Cintiq and continue the
calculation so we are quite flexible in
that regard so I think charm presented
that in a one slide very he highlighted
the manuals if you go inside the manuals
you'll find a wealth of information how
you can do that so but yeah I mean
extensibility is good but basically this
just means that at that point you have
to just roll your own code to plug in
yes yes I mean well I guess when you
mean you want to like completely
automatically layer construction I want
for example a brother set of primitives
that I can you know where I can combine
using the same language yeah I mean
since I could support a lot of
primitives we have like 40 plus
primitive operators that you can combine
you may not complete cover everything
but it's quite extensive I think the
most extensive is probably center flow
but we're catching up and if you are if
you find it missing your goal but again
does matter to now in the next iteration
over our area yeah thank you yeah I have
a coochie voltage of the binary keep
model yes did you do some evaluation
only the other platform put only the GP
of the views oh yeah so the the code
that we included in 2.0 release that's
actually serial code so it's about 7x
faster compared with regular convolution
of if you the the the ARM version that
we have demos I think that one is about
10 to 30 X faster can you feel it okay
fella
that's by the way that's the Alex Nair
model that we have experiment Islamic
xmod another level you need to work yeah
that one I believe it's not very good
analysis what we tested if you all we
hear it was okay coming at you
any other questions
great thank you very much for attending
thank you